yeah there we go yeah you should just
sit like that you know he always he
always says sometimes
daddy decides that he's going to just
open his hips up in a little bit i i do
a little yoga in the sunshine now if
you're wondering why i'm i'm in always a
good mood yeah sunshine you get down
with yoga well sunshine you know what
they're doing with sunshine now if
you've got an opi opiate problem you got
a little opiate problem a little vitamin
vitamin vitamin yeah what they're
finding is that a lot of times you ever
notice vancouver you take the wrong
right turn it's land on the walking dead
everybody there is portland portland
thank you everywhere that's really dark
and that's why
coffee found its
hubs there every every give people that
energy they needed a lot of cocaine a
lot of cocaine
uh what they're finding is that when you
have somebody who's on opiates and you
get them in the sunshine
it's way easier for them to get off it
it's really interesting really yes
really just a little sun yeah it's new a
lot of addicts have it's vitamin d a lot
of addicts when they have to like you'll
see a lot of them get into like marathon
running because the endorphins are 100
percent a hundred percent so what
they're doing now what they tell people
so they're like crazy
but when they when they tell people
about depression and stuff when you're i
mean well i think sweden has the highest
suicide rate you've been sweden in the
wintertime no yeah you get about an hour
of daylight and i'm not joking it's
crazy so uh elasticity is there's a
physio yeah there's a physiological
thing that happens to you
in the sun if you're having a rough day
or something just kidding
get in the sun but they don't have that
option i was having a rough day mark's
wait mark's like we're not going to the
gym today we're hiking i was like how
the [ __ ] do you want to hide felt good
he was like he was like yeah because
we're getting in i felt like a million
bucks definitely better
it's way better you know what's odd
about portland being so damn depressing
and like no sunshine is it isn't it like
the
oldest like strip club they have the
most strip the monster club
we've been to some of those we've been
some of those oh yeah we accidentally
went to one yeah yeah we went to mexico
yeah we were going to a restaurant
i was like whoa yes yeah they were
pillows
different look than you'd get in vegas
yeah yeah it did they would feel all
tattooed up different i mean
night and day it's like you're back in
the 18 days
like i just got this [ __ ] when you eat
when you're when you're living on motion
mostly lentils nuts and a lot of bread
tattoos and strawberries yellow tattoos
couldn't be white
couldn't be whiter okay and there's
something about white people when we
walked back there that one pale one she
had all these yeah she's all tattooed up
white when you get just white culture
like that it gets a little bit oh
it gets very fetishy about their
hairstyles i love pork rinds yeah i like
it i love it
there's a cozy feeling right it's like
maybe it's like we feel less threatened
it's not as aggressive is that what it
is yeah because remember we went to
seattle last time you were like bro you
know ain't nobody doing nothing out here
i'm remembering yeah the joke i could
rob a baby yeah robin
with the nerf gun yeah rogan one time
went he got back from portland or
seattle it was a long time ago before he
wanted to move there but he was like he
goes i don't like it i go why because
all the guys need a bunch of naps and
some vitamins
yeah there's no yeah it's a weird yeah
it's a very it's kind of just i like it
but i wouldn't want to live there yeah i
like going there cam haynes lives up
there and he's a [ __ ] guy he's he's a
guy's guy he's beware there's a lot of
where's he at he's in like [ __ ]
oregon like
like in the boonies it's just hard to
argue with the sunshine here man yeah
like you get you just you just can't
[ __ ] beat it
you get used to it eugene yeah that's
like the heart of it yeah oregon's where
the university of oregon is at it's nice
up there like i love i love arizona i
love i love my home state but i just
want it it gets a little tough living
there those summers get rough yeah they
get real i'm gonna now i'm 120 i'll be
there this weekend i'm gonna i'm gonna
do a little hiking maybe bro you always
hike when you go there i do remember
that's when i was like
though yeah now it's a good time yeah
yeah
yeah that summer hike though he did do a
summer hike yeah yeah he [ __ ] up yeah
he [ __ ] up
hey what's that what's that thing that
kevin bay sent you that was really good
for your your hamstrings
the pulse oh yeah yeah what's that
called um
yeah it's like a step stem machine i
have in my bronco why well i was not
gonna help with your foot well how about
my the old backy backs right oh yeah i'd
help with your back low back you want to
borrow it yeah i'd like to borrow it
what's that called what's that look it's
a it's essentially a stem unit
is it electrical yeah yeah so is it
called interferential treatment yeah it
works i have that too yeah yeah it's
just like make sure it's pulsates or
like you like uh it was interesting too
i was telling the guy who created it and
he's like uh he has some good points so
his whole like
perspective is like icing injuries is
such a thing of the past yeah he's like
it makes because uh
it restricts blood because kevin uh sent
me to that guy and he was like uh what
are you doing right now i'm like sitting
on ice he's like i know you think it
feels good it's the worst thing you can
do he's like we want to get blood
flowing through there that prevents the
blood right he's like the the we want to
heat that thing he's like so you need
the stem unit and heat he's like no cold
ever it's he was like it's such an old
school thing wow then why are they
coming out with these ice baths
is that well that's for inflammation but
you know then you're jumping out and
they're thinking by freezing it and then
going high yeah
but also ice bathrooms for a straight
injury that's just for like you know for
inflammation when you work out yeah
but this like and it makes sense when
the guy talks about it yeah he's like
you know we want blood flowing through
there and he's also he's like you can't
work out and run on your like so this is
gonna activate the muscle so it's firing
and we're getting all the nutrients did
you wear it all night
no you can't no you gotta do it uh
three hours a day spread out so hours
per hour
i would wear it when i was driving it
really helped oh my god yeah i'm 100 now
my hand like i'll be able to do tough
mudder april 9th damn
right now we're doing a 15k for the big
boys and then the 5k if you you know
just trying to figure it out extra extra
thick yeah it's the thick mudder and
they just released it we got special
thick mudder shirts dropping are you
doing it this time brian i won't be able
to make him
still messed up
dude we have a fight campaign that day i
think and then that and then no that
night so that day we have the tough
mudder that night we have fight campaign
is this one in la uh a san bernardino
[Music]
there it is tough mudder 15k 5k it's
april 9th 10 30 a.m glenn hill racing i
love that picture are you for that for
the fighting yeah
but uh yeah and you use the code thick
and you get ten percent on who's
fighting on that on that card uh i
forget but the the next companion
is march 19th it's for the ufc london
card and it's a free fight night card
it's at 1 1pm and it's dalia jeff dye
and adam 22 and me it's gonna be fun oh
a big boy that car brian by the way is
uh volkanovsky and korean zombie the the
one that you're doing april the one
is not yeah the one london's tom
aspinall we got
pam uh
yeah oh patty's on there yep i like that
guy who padded the batting this one
in the fight though right why are people
so hot high on him
i think he says energy no not his energy
he's [ __ ] talented they're not high
in energy
i didn't get that question but we don't
know do we who's he who's he i mean he
can kind of tell because he yeah he's
coming from that uh cage of fury okay
where you know connor came from
everybody came out of there yeah if
you're coming out of there you know
what's his thing striking mostly or
everything he's he's pretty good at
everything yeah yeah he's a badass
though he's got him arnold arnold allen
dan hooker on there volkanov aspinall
that's a good card man
paul craig a lot of russians a lot of
russians gunnar nelson that's a good
card
also the the the free fight nights for
the reason they do well for the fight
companions because the pay-per-view it's
80 bucks you know people paying 80 bucks
i met i met jamie varner yesterday we
were at wally's old school yeah
wc yeah good guy he was oh at wally's
that restaurant yeah
the uh that i said i was the waitress
there i was talking about i said i
mentioned this on my podcast she goes
the guys over there said that they heard
about wallace on a podcast they were
here i go yeah it's mine it's my podcast
and then jamie varner came over
you got to take care of your head dude
your brain is so important your brain is
you i work look i work my body as you
know i i wear fine duds but what about
what's going on people leave out their
brain and maybe you're a sad panda and
that's where our friends that better
help they sponsor this episode of firing
the kid listen if there is something
interfering with your happiness it's
preventing you from achieving your goals
you need better help yes so assist your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
now under 48 hours yeah dude it's not
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online the service is available
worldwide you can log on to your account
anytime send a message your therapist
you get timely and thoughtful responses
plus you can schedule weekly video phone
sessions and you will never have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy god it's much more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy financial aid is also available
better help once you start living a
happier life right now all right visit
betterhelp.com
fighter that's better h-e-l-p and join
the over two million people wow we've
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
quit talking your friends your sister
your aunt to get with a professional can
actually make a difference give them ten
percent off dude
all right it's a special offer for the
fire and the kid
listeners and viewers you get 10 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
fighter good rx sometimes you pay too
much for prescriptions you don't know
i'm sick of overpaying for prescriptions
yeah they can vary as much it's a hustle
hundred dollars for per per pharmacy i
have no idea i show up like 110 dollars
like what rx dude dude good rx good
discounts let you compare find the
lowest prices of pharmacies new year
like cbs kroger walgreens rite aid bonds
and more and you'll always you'll always
know what you're paying before you get
to that that's everything zaddy even if
you have insurance or medicare good rx
often beat your copay price in fact
anytime you need to fulfill the
prescription just checking goodrx could
save you up to 80
taking control of your prescription cost
is free and easy with goodrx check the
website or download the free goodrx app
all right so for simple smart savings on
your prescriptions check goodrx go to
goodrx.com fighter that's goodrx.com
fighter goodrx.com fighter good rx is
not insurance but can be used instead of
insurance in 2021 garage used to save an
average of 79
on retail prescription prices gaston and
jamie varner came over
say what's up that's the spot is he a
coach now he's a i think uh uh he's
actually not fighting he's anymore at
all he's no i know he's retired yeah the
whole super old school oh yeah he's
gonna yeah he was a wc he broke his leg
and kept fighting he [ __ ] his leg up
literally broke it and and
kept swinging
oh he's from phoenix glendale
[Music]
on those guys
let's see if on our continuous studies
uh we're introducing the ufc
okay after graduation you worked at
boston scientific before transitioning
to stem cell domain all right awesome
check out the big brain on brad yeah
so we got we got him and we got cejudo
out of phoenix as well yeah those guys
were all asking us though right he
wasn't saying
no olympic wrestler no i know he's a i
know he's a gold medalist no and cejudo
is a california kid his coach is his
coach yeah i don't think so he is yeah i
think he is born he went to college
he was raised in l.a though he says born
and older yeah born yeah yeah oh okay
weird he went to high school in arizona
yeah he might have been he was born here
though yeah where'd he go to college
uh i don't know where he went to college
so inspired by his older brother cejudo
um let's see henry also became fourth
time his freshman sophomore year titles
were in arizona and that before he moved
to colorado spring so he didn't even go
to college yeah he just started went
straight to training for the national
team jesus yeah
while in high school cejudo won the
fargo national title and freestyle
and then right from high school
full-time united states olympic training
center in colorado springs
he prepared for junior world
championships placed
that's a whole different um that kind of
yeah but yeah he was born in l.a he's an
l.a kid he has a great story here in l.a
but yeah
you're right though chappelle he did do
uh some of [ __ ] in phoenix fighting out
of phoenix yeah
he has gyms out of there right yep
he's a nice guy we met him he came to
the shows last time we were in phoenix
phoenix yeah he's a great nice guy he's
blown up as a coach yeah he's helping
everybody for him he's helping everybody
yeah i watched him i rewatched the fight
between him and mighty mouse his second
fight that was a good fight yeah
that's where he just saw greatness yeah
he's the beast unbelievable super beast
yep he had a great record too yeah oh
yeah i think two division championships
yeah i mean yeah yeah yeah he lost a
mighty mouse yeah quick too but then he
just beat him yeah he beat him yeah
that's right he lost to joe joseph
benavidez too oh [ __ ] oh his last fight
was 20 oh yeah that's he retired 2020
yeah
yeah he wants to come back and fight
volkanovsky but i don't know
that i'd love to see that fight me too i
would
he's like he sounds like he's set
because he's all about he's like show me
the money man let me know i got my bat
so he'd go up to 45 and fight vulcan wow
that's that's uh because where he beat
tj dillashaw for a flyweight yep at 25.
25 a flight yeah that's fine so 25 belt
35 belt then you're trying to get the 45
imagine
i mean and that's a tough fight for
volkanovsky it's a tough fight for he's
[ __ ] good but and he wants to do it
but the ufc is like why are they why why
wouldn't they do that
because he wants a certain amount of
money and if he's just like that's not
what we do man to watch him fight
volkanowski to be a three-division
champion oh my god and then also olympic
that'd be simple
why did he retire
just
was like i just he's like i'm good i
need more money if i'm keep doing this
what do you think the lightweights don't
get paid what's he wrong around that
what do you think he walks around
like 150 155 no i doubt it is that right
because volkonowski at one point was
something like 240 240 yeah but not i
mean now he's nowhere near that yeah
well he's down to 45 but that must be a
hell of a cut for him because he's uh we
should be a rugby kid
he's just a man yeah if if i feel like
so who wants to put you on your back
he's going to put you on your back no
matter who you are i don't care who you
are you're going on your back yeah you
took [ __ ] mighty mouse yeah but
volkonowski can punch you in the face
super hard
super [ __ ] he can kick and he can
kick like a mule yeah like an australian
mule yeah and what can he keep is he
strong enough to keep the huda from
taking him down no no no
he's getting it he's getting anybody
there i wish they would make the fight
happen but the ufc is just not going to
pay i would love to see that me too
it's just not happening
the question is
he'd have to close distance but in the
meantime he might get his [ __ ]
headgear yeah
a great fight but but why why do they
not get paid as much that weight smaller
weights or people are like a big drone
yeah
was so dominant for years and nobody
cared god dominant like pound for pound
best in the world no one flyweight no
one that's just
smaller guys people just don't
appreciate it yeah damn
the casual fans even though the fights
are like [ __ ] dope the casual fan the
casual fantasy there's like time yeah
casual fans not too many what
i mean correct me about wrong not too
many knockouts no the finish rate is not
high yeah when you have
mighty mouse would even finish dudes but
they just yeah that's why bran mourinho
and some of those guys who are getting
finishes it's great
but it's just they're small so
people don't like they don't understand
the talent and the technique they want
finishes yeah but the element the the
thing also that you could say is that
when you're your size the heavyweights
205
it's so dangerous the minute they touch
you sometimes you can go out yeah and
also
i don't know that at heavyweight you
know when you're when you're at that
weight your head is almost the same size
or basically the same size as a huge man
okay so you can take you can take more
chances you can slip well the thing is
170 and up at what so whenever they do
the pound rankings and this is no shade
on mighty mouse i never had them for
pound for pound number one because to
brian's point if mighty mouse zigs when
when he should have zagged and gets hit
he'll go oh i won't do that again right
at 179. if you zig when you should have
zagged it's over it's it's a wrap it's
over you can't make that mistake yeah 55
he can maybe 45 35 125 for sure yeah
dude 185 205 heavyweight you zig when
you should have zagged you're a
highlight that's interesting that's like
jon jones has always been bound for
bound number one yes yes yes because
when you watch that guy tied to a vodka
right here you may not have uh all the
technique but when you stand and the
stakes are you're you're going to get
enough stuff but the stakes are just
higher yeah it's much higher that's why
heavyweights
for as long as fighting has been around
i've always been the main draw yeah it's
like that that's why when francis walks
in the room it's like oh that's the bath
man yeah yeah and they also look then he
is the baddest man on the planet and
in other words they also look so
astonishing they're just so they look
how the the the general population
yes
thinks
of
like that i think i think back to that
derek lewis fight when he fought the uh
russian guy get his name we knocked him
out yeah yeah because it looked like the
dude yeah volkov it looked like
technically he's way better yeah he
looked like he had him but he's lighting
him up just
that won't happen that flyweight yeah no
no never okay no i think the other thing
with all again all due respect to
anybody at 45 55 as tough as those guys
are and you take colby covington you
take those guys as tough as those
[ __ ] are uh-huh
you put them in the ring with any
heavyweight
who's yeah that's silly though right no
i'm just saying that people but what's
weird about it is like technique-wise
yeah
though
oh my god they've got them like henry
and volca
[ __ ] max holloway and brian dude
no one's [ __ ] with their what
jiu jitsu is stupid right it's just yeah
but even as [ __ ] striking
yeah yeah so it's like their technique
is light years back
heavyweight like think about greg hardy
[ __ ] you know he's whatever 37 years
old
i'll try it out yeah he's in the ufc if
you're a flyweight and you're like i'll
try it out you're you're gonna get
you're involved you'll never make the
news that's interesting because
in the world there's so many more people
at 155 pounds than under yeah the
competition so i thought it was just
like all around like people just [ __ ]
with it all together i'm not saying that
people don't you know when you're like
having you know finding finding training
partners your size is it's a nightmare
so
say it again so when you're his size and
you need training partners because
you're going to fight another monster
yeah you're going to fight a guy's 270
okay okay trying to find trying to find
not only training partners your size but
guys who can mimic what you're going to
face is a [ __ ] nightmare right so
hey to have them flown in but if i'm
smaller they have like you've got you're
all guys
everywhere smaller guys small guys have
it easier but also their level of
difficulty to make it so much harder so
it was so like with the technique thing
is it just tougher to have that strong
level of technique as a bigger guy
no there's some guys that have it but
they grew up fighting yeah and then
those smaller guys they're like the
speed they're good at everything so to
go back to you then you got in it
late in the game i guess he was playing
different sports that paid more money
right yeah so if you're his size in
america or you're greg hardy greg hardy
was a pro bowler so you're right you're
you're talking about you're you're not
getting gravitated towards
nfl oh yeah okay
you're making real money 100 percent
you're not going to go in the ufc
yeah no the real athletes you have to
really want to [ __ ] do the use like
if tiger's a big boy and he's like dad
it's nfl or ufc i'm like what are you
doing yeah
yeah you're going to nfl and you're
making all the money that's right and
then you'll have savings yes you have so
so yeah
yeah and then ufc it's like you have
nothing dude and there's also no
blueprint to get to the ufc so the real
way to make money on usc because it
obviously it seems like there's able to
do so you got to win you got guys like
connor obviously obviously win win
but like nba of a certain weight class
by the way you know you'd be amazed that
it's it's but as long as you i don't
care what as long as you win i mean like
the [ __ ] you money comes what about the
ticket
what do you mean like or like the
pay-per-view
is it pay-per-view yeah if you win very
few people
very if you're champion you get
pay-per-view oh no that's why i'm saying
just win and you make
money but [ __ ] you money is different
yeah like connor has [ __ ] you money dc
there's some certain guys biz being made
a ton of money yeah there's certain guys
that get that [ __ ] you money mm-hmm but
you know you gotta win you got also you
got to win you have to win
like nothing is better when khabib
because makachev hates the spotlight
he's doing interviews he does and it's
my favorite it's one of my favorite
videos ever in sports
and he's he's getting ready to fight
bobby green and do all the press for it
and we have bobby green on uh food truck
next week uh but uh makachev is doing
all the interviews and he's getting he
just hates so he just hates that stuff
yeah yeah
and khabib goes this can all go away
just lose just lose tomorrow this all
goes away it's really simple
just lose you don't have to do this
anymore i see that he's dead seriously
yeah
she goes i gotta steal what they say he
was just lose you know what you this all
stops it's really easy just lose
tomorrow this is
no english he was just loose
that's all you got to do he was just
very he was it's very simple mike ah
that's so good he was just losing you
don't have to worry about it that puts
it right in perspective [ __ ] don't
don't
don't be over this dude yeah yeah what
yeah this is incredible the territory
heavy lies the question
look
because it's your job about too much
media
like coach javier say
if you don't want
just
like like like coach said if you don't
make lara integrity just lose
nobody gonna come you know you have to
lose you have to make champion just lose
just lose he goes it's very simple
who cares if you're tired i'm so tired
nobody cares how great is he nobody
that's hilarious isn't that great
anatomy of a fighter have do you watch
him no fight or watch oh dude i got one
of the best youtube channels really yeah
chris you got to watch this [ __ ] yeah
yeah i love that stuff that's [ __ ]
helpful yeah you would love that behind
the scenes a lot
could you get in better shape or the i
mean that's just
yeah monster yeah how funny is that just
lose ben it's all good
it's really simple so true too
fantastic how funny is that that is
when you get to that level it's like
you heavy lies the crown like frank
mayor used to say that and even rhonda
it's like you want to be champion then
you got to do championship yeah where
the ufc's bank on you selling this
pay-per-view so while your opponent is
the contender they're doing half the
interviews you're flying to new york and
you're on espn you're doing all this
[ __ ] and then you got to fly into you
know the fight you were dating rather at
the height of her powers
and so you probably saw it firsthand man
that's not that's a lot of pressure
heavy lies the ground yeah yeah yeah
people like what connor deals with i
can't imagine i can't imagine i can't
imagine no such a badass dude i know
such a [ __ ] embarrassment
and then he also delivers me crazy
people hate on champions who are
long-term champions or people who just
keep putting themselves out there you
know how hard it is he could he could
stop but it's just so hard and he's just
willing to constantly and always put
himself out there i don't like the way
he behaves sometimes i'll be honest no i
don't co-sign a lot of yeah
but man
yeah especially him a guy forcing nature
force of nature oh no one like a man
came out of nowhere two in a way like
decided to be that like
was for a long time you know was was a
just a fighter a journeyman i mean did
well but i wouldn't say it not a
tournament but just decided he was going
to walk away i'm going to take over you
guys you're going to walk away in this
coach and something happened yeah that
just sparked them that's cool quick
question when you talk about the money
thing with the ufc
have you heard about the recent thing
with the mlb lockout yes they're missing
games but also you play too many games
i'm not mad at it but carry on yeah yeah
well it's just
because i think they're complaining
about their pay as well
but it's just like hilarious because if
you know what i mean well it's hilarious
because they pay they make so much money
that's what i thought and it's also a 50
50 split that no one has a better uh
like uh
players union association then major
league basically okay major league
baseball is the blueprint what every
league should go off of it's 50 50 dude
yeah they make so much [ __ ] crap
it's so off the minimum and i don't know
what the holdout is i don't know if the
owner's trying to change something i
don't know what the details on it yeah i
think but in general those baseball
players are s
taking i was hearing a little bit about
it but i just thought it was interesting
when you think about the basketball
again take they have so much power
the the players and the uh
mlb and nba have all the power like
their their unions whatever yeah
damn monsters and they make so much
[ __ ] that's why like that's why
baseball you see five years 500 million
dollars five and also it's guaranteed
nba
whatever six years 700 million dollars
guaranteed yeah so if i never play again
you owe me that money bro [ __ ] now aaron
rodgers just signed some crazy deal i
think right like the biggest deal in nfl
history yeah which deserving i know i
was hoping he'd come to my denver
broncos but we got the second best
russell wilson yeah
afc west is lit as [ __ ] dude
the thing about we got
derek carr we got uh homeboy from san
diego was it uh hubert or whatever and
then you got patrick mahomes chase not
bad and then you got russell wilson yeah
i'm [ __ ] crunk about it dude that's
your denver broncos oh die hard my dad
would not quit calling me yesterday
we love the broncos he's like finally we
got one because we haven't had one since
peyton manning right right we finally
got one i was like well i wish it was
aaron rodgers but this ain't a bad
second but and then i saw the rumors and
you know lauren landau who's their
strength coach
i uh i said hey any truth to
russell come in and he goes maybe and
lorne
is like you know he doesn't want to be
the guy that leaks it out but
maybe from him i'm like oh [ __ ] it's
going down dude yeah now we gave up
everything for him uh-huh but it makes
sense you know so because he's a
wonderful how does that work we gave up
uh drew lockett which is whatever drew
lock which is fine uh we gave over a
tight end who's a badass
i forget his uh
front or something like that it doesn't
matter that's okay and then we gave up
uh first second round picks next year
first second round picks the following
year that's a lot about right now there
ain't a russell wilson in any of those
draft classes he's a proven warrior also
he's had no help for years he's such a
baller yeah here's the problem with the
nfl though
is when you pay a quarterback you'll
notice when you pay a quarterback so
much money because the salary cap you
don't have money for other players yeah
this is why tom brady's [ __ ]
brilliant because he went no no
i don't want all the money in the world
i want you to sign other guys so i win
championships i'm already set
financially yes my wife makes more money
than all you [ __ ] so i'm all set dude
he's worth 450 million so he goes i'm
good on money
pay the other guys so we can win yeah
russell wilson went give me all the
money and then okay cool you're not
gonna have offensive line enjoy that and
he got lit up and got hurt last year
but him on the broncos dude we're super
contenders babies wait so did he take a
pick up for the broncos or no absolutely
no no but still our defense is lit we
got judy as receiver yeah i'm excited
man so you still as a broncos fan it's
been tough
it's been tough and afc west is so good
we're like we're [ __ ] yeah we get a
russell wilson
i was hoping roger's my favorite player
in the league is he oh yeah so should
have the vaccination stuff
hold up cooper cups my favorite
but that's your boyfriend but
but aaron's
it was yeah aaron's daddy here's daddy
here and zaddy cooper and roger
you say zaddy zaddy now dude cooper
there's a guy i finally
i finished uh
love is blind last night the reunion
yeah there's an indian guy on there i
forget his name
the worst person in the world
but the worst person in the world
because you don't watch it no
so you know i love his blind works right
you go in the pods you make connection
he's only dated white blonde white girls
he's never dated someone in his race an
indian yeah he makes connection he
doesn't know it with the indian girl
pretty girl really pretty girl
like she has a great heart
awesome girl have you watched a cat or
no so she's dope she's she like this
girl is great they make connection and
uh they're saying stuff and then he's
like oh are you ending you're like yeah
he's like i never dated a brown girl
before she goes i've never dated a brown
guy before usually i date blonde guys
she goes he was like they blonde girls
it's connection there's all stuff going
on they're in [ __ ] mexico you know so
they see each other they see each other
and he's like wow you're gorgeous blah
blah
she's never had a guy at her meet her
family ever she's super strict
great human being he goes there meets
the family all that stuff
then off camera like he's talking he's
like she i'm just not a track doorman
starts like clowning her physical
appearance and starts doing it to other
guys too
like just like not i'm just not
attracted to her so it's like you know
shaming her a little bit like what is
happening so he becomes the villain on
the show
[ __ ] she finds out he's talking [ __ ] she
you know she's like clearly we're not
getting married
dude during the reunion this dude i mean
he needs somebody like what what are you
doing dude he's
so outrageous you he's talking [ __ ] you
would watch it and be like how does
somebody not beat him up there's one big
black guy who's like i prom he like he's
like you don't speak for all this dude
like because this black guy got married
to this black girl and he's like it
worked the experiment worked for me
that's your perspective it worked for me
dude and he keeps talking [ __ ] and the
black guy says something they don't tell
us on the subtitles and the black guy
goes i promise you don't keep going down
this road and the little any guy goes
you should try me i'm like
dude i was like kill him right now bring
him up he only he only said it because
he knew he wasn't going to get rid of
dude if i was on that show and that
little indian dude was i'd be like you
well you simply have to shut the [ __ ] up
yeah yeah and so listen i'll squeeze now
one one part i kind of agree with i
haven't been on he he talks about
um he goes this experiment's stupid the
experiment should be love is blurry is
it that guy yeah that's him he's the
worst human in the world and so he goes
it should be love is blurry because he
goes
you guys are taking out physical
attraction he goes i'm just not
attracted to the women in this room and
then the host is nicholas shea and his
wife i love his name
i forget his wife's name you know what
vanessa
uh
you know what i'm out yes i know
she's super pretty he's super dude
what is it it's vanessa vanessa
in front of nicolas her husband he was
i'm just not attracted to anybody on the
show it is i don't mean to be mean i'm
just not no one's asking by the way he's
going yeah
milano
milano
so he goes
yeah he goes i'm just not attracted to
the women on the show like you can hate
me all you want he was like in this room
i only attracted vanessa it is what it
is in front of the husband
and i was like how does nobody whip his
ass
he's never had his ass he's never had
his promise he's never been punched in
the [ __ ] face there's no way and
sometimes you need that i don't know how
you're going i don't know how he oh
i don't know how he got away with it but
because he's on the show there's
security guards around and he knows
as josh barnett said you need more guys
and then the one of the guys on the show
is named shane he looks like cooper cup
if he did all the cocaine in the world
the guys uncocaine the entire series
really that's the girl wait go back
that's the girl that he was mean to
making fun of her looks yeah her culture
even though he's indian like just a
piece of [ __ ] and she's like a [ __ ]
sweetheart like such a good person
everybody loves her he just was [ __ ] i
bet you a lot of this stuff is scripted
i don't think so no no
you don't think that [ __ ] talking i
think it is no this there's no way this
is the guy right that's the guy who
wanted to beat up the engine oh that's
that's the guy that was ready yeah that
guy will beat his ass him and his wife
aren't gonna work out but that's
whatever you don't think so absolutely
not he's like my girl my girl he goes
out all the time the girls like homebody
reads books yeah first night they were
like by themselves he's like alright
well going out with the boys was that
like some bar drinking to like two in
the morning
it's funny how
how this kind of [ __ ] is uh so popular
like but now what they're doing because
in the season finale and that's the new
show the new show is brilliant the new
show is couples that have been together
for like five years and one wants to get
married have kids and the other is
hesitant so what they do is put them in
a situation where they meet two other
people that they think are going to
connect and then the show you gotta
decide if you can get married and stay
with your your like man or women that's
intense or
go with one of these new guys
it looks so good
yeah have you seen i don't know they
don't in japan have you ever seen their
candid camera shows their reality shows
big brother no they take it like they
take a couple steps too far yeah where
they had the uh
famous singer
and uh and her manager they get in the
car
and this is the joke ready for this they
he's the manager's there she's there
mask gunmen
grab them
tie them up put them in the backseat of
their own car well that's pretty is that
this is
or that's right they don't even know
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah i know
it's like their version of the
production company though um is that
what they're doing yeah oh oh okay and
the guys get the guy's a mask get in the
car and drive them on a ramp into a semi
close the semi
come out and say we're going to hold you
for ransom and start integra
interrogating sounds fantastic it's
unbelievable the girl's crying i mean
there's no way that show would make it
an american never never meanwhile the
manager this is her manager he's these
are kisses
these are no these are kidnappers with
guns right
the [ __ ] manager starts fighting them
starts fighting them and he's like kind
of a martial arts guy he's screaming in
japan i mean what a badass do you see
who he really is in real life
yeah that's what i'll say it's like
their version of punk but that's the
kind of [ __ ]
the managers would run i got one even
better they they they have a bath house
and these old men
are they they go to have baths these are
japanese they're like
70.
and they have the dude come down a slide
into what he thinks is going to be water
it's like
it's old dudes yeah it's an old man he's
naked as [ __ ] he's naked
he comes sliding down he thinks he's
going to get into a warm pool it's
called the probably in good shape oh no
yeah yeah
and he slides down
he slides into a dining room
with a but 15 formal diners dude this
show is fantastic
and they're all like this no it's like a
live squid game it's like it's like a
live squid game like that yeah and you
see like
he goes out with his flat little ass
hilarious dude
is this on netflix
it's not it should be it's the greatest
[ __ ] i've ever seen they had that kind
of [ __ ] where you just be like oh my
[ __ ]
there's a show on tlc it's on hulu it's
called hot and heavy
it's handsome dudes handsome loose turn
but attractive dudes who are into really
fat girls
now when i say fat i don't mean like
thick like you're talking a little cuz
like where you lose the
i'm talking she went to the doctor she's
five one four hundred pounds there are
men who see that guy he's a handsome
dude dude he just loves this big girl
yeah and he would he he brings her to
the bar to introduce some of his friends
and his friends like why
like what is this
i'll talk to my girl about it i go
but if that's what you're into like who
gives something like if that's like
first i like i like i love it i like
small waist big asses that's in my dna i
like your fat ass skinny waist i can't
help it there's nothing i can do
this guy i don't know what happened he's
wired to like guys
well he and then one guy the one girl
wants to get out the one girl wants to
get uh tummy surgery and he's like whoa
whoa whoa why would you do that and then
when they interview him on his own he's
like i actually would like her to get
fatter
oh god that's like bro what else i want
to get bigger and i was like
she [ __ ] snacked but look at like
he just loves her
her
three friends who are just
massive getting the hot tub and all the
water leaves the hot tub and they're all
but they're having a great time
and then and then and then and then the
one
go go
go to the it's like shallow house go up
ah it's not though don't know he'd be
pissed about there are guys that are
truly
uh
see the couple with the kitchen yeah
wow so he's a super chubby chaser right
yeah and then they're like having a nice
like she doesn't like to go out of the
house right because you know yeah it's a
bummer so finally he talks to her
getting out of the house just so [ __ ]
up he talks he's like let's just get ice
cream she's like okay let's get ice
cream they're getting ice cream she has
her ice cream and some guy drives by and
goes enjoy the ice cream you fat cow
dude it ruined the entire episode i was
like and i told my girl she goes do you
think they planted that and went i do
because
i said it's really [ __ ] up i do
because any guy that's going to some
hater that's going to say it out loud
for sure is going to cause
like no one's going to just not cuss
yeah yeah he'd be like hey you [ __ ]
cow move you fat [ __ ] he everything was
like an [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] terrible person yeah well
the husband you do that husband goes
pull over you piece of [ __ ]
before the guy was like
what's up bro
it's josh barnett gets out of the car
yeah no the but the the poor it's just
like that's sad but no that's a
condition right yeah it's like a thing
where i don't know what's going on uh
thyroid right it's a lot of things oh no
it's uh don't shut your mouth
it's a lot of things i mean you can
blame it on thyroid sure you know what
they do some people have that problem do
you know do you know i told my guy i
said would you
i said would you rather have it's a fun
game i said would you rather be 400
pounds or you know 400 ain't much you
can do yeah you can get the tummy
surgery you're 400 pounds
and then get the surgery your skins
would be melting off yeah that's a
nightmare you look like frank stein they
cut all the skin off it's a nightmare
for you would you rather be 400 pounds
or have one arm in the best body ever
and you can eat whatever you want be
shredded i told my girl one arm she goes
you're crazy i go
you know sick a [ __ ] arm one arm and
i'll get a [ __ ]
carbon fiber like robot looking like
jeffy i'm shredded
yes
and she's like oh 400 pounds like no
[ __ ] weight you know you know how
uncomfortable that is
it's so uncomfortable but even she like
works in office she's like they just
don't make offices for people like me
i'm like what what's standard office
league it's hard to do we can't
we can't build the office for 400 pound
people
like if you watch my 600 pound life
when they
when they have to go to their doctor
visits no you just don't call up your
buddy hey can you pick me up
well no because you're 700 pounds for
that oh no we have no car no get a car
you need one of those scooters
a scooter that'd be fun yeah but it's
not disneyland right
on a scooter in disneyland we can't do
scooters no no we have to call an
ambulance and then the entire
firefighter team comes in and has to
like wrap you in a [ __ ] sheet and
then
seven guys
seven eight guys have to carry you out
of the house into the back of an
ambulance okay that is cleared out you
got one arm just to get you to check in
with the doctor
it's a nightmare
now you know what they try to do with
those people now they do fecal implants
excuse me you know that yeah poo poo
they take the [ __ ] from a skinny guy
like me
and they put it in your [ __ ] for
because it'll change the bacteria in
your gut
and i wish it was that easy yeah it's a
tough one but they've had some they're
trying everything huh yeah yeah if that
if that worked i would take your like
you can ram it into my ass does that
person i shouldn't be your [ __ ]
i [ __ ] i'd have a funnel and i take a
[ __ ] right into your [ __ ] and you
know that's been done before right it's
probably a fetish well it's telling you
yeah i know i take a [ __ ] in your ass
that'll seem that'll seem like they're
like this around your around your old
wrinkly brown eyes i'm gonna go like
this and go well that's what you and
then tomorrow i show up just skinny as
[ __ ] yep then you're scared
what is this movie human centipede that
i was told i have to watch oh that's og
i don't know yeah because you know what
that is
yeah
yeah
yourself
yeah that's not a good thing
would do that came out too deranged as i
said it's og they surgically mouth to
anus form a human centipede
yeah i i don't want to watch that no i'm
not it's a horror film and then he he
drugs you and puts you ass to mouth yeah
i mean something like that yeah and then
you're you wake up and your your arms
have been looking there's a picture look
at the picture yeah someone's gasping no
to the right chin well no it's a big
problem where it says the guardian yeah
no and then so i guess there you go the
guy at the end doesn't
yeah that one dude yeah that one
well that's that's a real issue huh
that's flame
yeah i'm not into it also how the hell
comes i got a good show for you guys on
netflix it's called the worst neighbor
the worst roommate ever it's like a
six-year-old
first episode of that it's good is it
good it starts off slow i'm like
somebody looks intense i'm like somebody
needs to kill somebody here what a bad
human the first thing i was talking
about bad what her criminal record oh my
[ __ ] guy so is that old lady and then
she would take like people in like uh
like older people into her house yep and
saying she was helping him and she would
drug him
kill him to collect their social
security check and bury him in the
backyard she killed like nine this old
lady she's a serial killer but she had a
box of kittens that she was feeding with
a bottle just so you know you saw that
she was no she had a cover how many how
many bodies does she have on her nine
eight nine but she got she got uh life
in prison for three the other ones they
couldn't prove
but they they were buried in her
backyard yeah i mean got away with it
forever for i mean she got away with it
she died at 82 in prison wow
and then the next one's i did i just
watched half of it it's a guy who's a
squatter they can't get him out of the
house uh-huh i assume he kills him
better yeah they need to hit that [ __ ]
hard man because that that first
uh that first one was
somebody [ __ ] kill somebody takes a
while though like say that say the
killing first and then i'm investing
yeah you know what i mean there's some
people that look at other people as
objects they're not people they're just
things they're just like that bottle or
something yeah there's something
sociopath born different yeah yeah putin
believes the same thing
is that what they call serial killer
sociopaths
yeah and are
all serial killers are narcissists uh
sociopaths like they have no and they
have no remorse
zero you everybody don't give
you can see them it's fascinating
actually you can see them
their whole life and they they have one
burnt bridge after another they have
they have
a thousand falling outs with a thousand
people and it's always their fault yeah
it's never one common denominator
but they don't realize they don't
realize it even after 60 years old they
don't realize it it's just think about
it i just think it's like but just like
the bdk killer like dude he hung like
four year olds and seven year olds
like just think about how yeah
and like in that and then that like
scene of seven like or he sat down a
little brother watch him kill the sister
yeah think about that dude it's so
demented it's sick man it's so crazy to
me
god damn yeah it's got dark souls
that show is good
i know i don't have any shows man i ran
out of pam and tommy no on who it's so
everyone's been talking highly so good i
just finished it yeah
it's about uh the pam anderson and tommy
lee sexton i'm in and it's good and they
show everything everyone's wearing
prosthetics there's like they show tommy
lee's like fake dick dude that's the
first like porno type of thing i've seen
when he honks the
the horn on the with his dick
or the boat with his big dick he's got a
dick on him a boy got a dick on him it's
good that girl uh who plays pamela
anderson her name's like lily it's a
mini so good yeah she's my killer then i
guess eight episodes she's so [ __ ]
good she gets the mannerisms down to a t
oh and the show popped off so hard that
netflix actually approached pamela
anderson to see if she wanted to do a
documentary about her life to get her
side of the story yeah so she's doing it
oh that was amazing
were they uh were they aware of the sex
tapes they were oh yeah they shot it
so yeah it was like a home camera
videotape there were a sick one yeah
yeah there were videos of like their
purpose right uh no they were robbed
because the premise of this story is
that like tommy had screwed a
construction worker over and he broke
into the house stole a safe and in the
safe there was the tape when they looked
through it he was like oh i'm going to
make money off of this because he owes
me money and so he sells the tape and
that's how it got like i guess but did
they get yeah right yeah yeah well then
yeah you can't do that oh it didn't work
out no now there's lawsuits if like
someone releases like let's say you sent
someone a dick pic and they released
that on the internet
oh yeah yeah and this was during the
time when the internet was brand new so
there were really no laws on what you
could and could not post and so like
their sex tape in combination with the
internet started to just like spiral out
of control where they couldn't stop and
legally had no ground so shut down the
first time yeah
did you hear uh the first
kind of i guess lawsuit in the metaverse
happen
some dude like grabbed some girl in the
metaverse like
you know and then she pressed charges
against him what take him to court
he kept himself why the [ __ ] would he do
that think about being the metaverse
yeah right
like who the [ __ ] does that's your
character man
get the [ __ ] out of talking she's just
suing him why because that caused her
emotional distress or some [ __ ] i mean
if you got them i don't know how you i
don't know how it works right
versus goggles on and then some dudes
just [ __ ] yeah you know i don't think
it's suck but you're not it's not real
it's like a video game it's like i saw a
guy he was clubbing like baby seals is i
can't remember the comic's name he's so
[ __ ] funny from canada and he was
just [ __ ] clubbing seals and he's
like guys in real life no people like oh
and he goes guys
guys this is this is it's not a real
seal it's a fake seal it's not even
existing watch i can [ __ ] it and it's
fine
because now i'm slowing its head on yeah
who said that he was so funny oh look i
found a puppy and he just spiked it he
goes yeah okay though
but it's true he's a really funny comic
man um a monster but the metaverse we're
headed that way you know like if that's
what they're doing
are you guys invested into it nope i
could never do it it's transhumanism
it's a weird thing weird thing i mean
we're going to have no choice in the
future yeah
yeah it's so weird why i don't subscribe
to it yeah no
it's such a strange all right jim what
do you got
see the zebra helps you save on your
insurance with housing cars appliances
dude prices are going up everywhere
including insurance yes luckily for us
our friends at the zebra are here to
rescue us they make it so easy to save
hundreds on car or home insurance well
they come in just minutes car and home
quotes from every major insurance
company side by side giving you all the
facts you need to make the right
decision wow it's the fast way to find
the right coverage at the right price
all from a provider you can trust in
fact the zebra saves people an average
of 922 bucks
a year on car and home insurance
combined plus
they do it all in five minutes what's up
oh man save time and money in minutes
show your support for this show the
firing kid by going to this special url
the zebra.com fighter and get your free
quote today that's
the zebra.com fighter
hey b guess what your boys head to
nashville what yep i'm heading to
nashville i got a special guest jumping
on stage with me i get the usual
you optimize i'm optimizing i know you
got your whiskey but you got to optimize
before that you got to be clear in the
head you got to have energy dude our
mood's got to be right nothing makes me
more clear in the head than nashville
zaney's this thursday friday saturday
the end of the month i'm in chicago
schaumburg improv get your tickets at
thickboy.com also thick mudder april 9th
10 30 a.m run the 15k the 5k use promo
code thickboy for 10 percent off to run
with the screw
we also got thick boy shirts drop in uh
friday well now i got it i got big
[ __ ] i got phoenix this weekend
as you know i mean i got oh it's going
to be good phoenix is going to be oh it
will be good i'm doing a sunday show
friday sunday i never do that then i
made me sad yeah then i got louisville
kentucky you look like phil collins on
stage i probably will that's okay i got
louisville kentucky and then i got miami
miami the 25th to the 27th yeah salsa on
stage it's going to be so this is going
to be fun brian's going to be in a thong
now i need some help though can you help
me out i need some energy
right yeah yeah your boy did 225 27
times a day after lift in 3 15 12 times
225 27 i think that would put me in the
top 10 in the combine yeah that's no
joke but i can't pop your hamstrings i
can't catch a football anymore that's
okay whatever but uh the only reason i'm
able to lift that much because of on its
supplements that's right kids they're
protein powders they're creating
genetics glutamine
but you keep it devalue my hard work
whether you keep it together you feed
the machine you got alpha brain for your
dude your boy you sleep well with the
melatonin zaddy here blew out his
hamstring
my recovered with honest supplements
your boy's 100 percent now oh no listen
right
i'll never get out of third gear ever
again in my life or or we'll just warm
you up for an hour and then maybe you'll
try it once unless russia invades i'm
not gonna have sex there you go exactly
how about that but if you want if you
want your spirulina you want your
chlorella you want your food how about
coffee protein bars warrior bars they
got everything it truly is the best
supplements i'm sick of telling you guys
how goddamn good it is save 10 off you
got fitness gear you got streaming
fitness on-demand workouts at home
streaming fitness steel macy's club
macy's kettlebells
sandbags hydro core bags keeps going
dude you want to be certified go to
honest certifications we got you man you
got dope gear as well
on it dot com slash fighter 10 off the
entire goddamn website audit.com fighter
10 off
oh by the way um adam ray
you know the community yeah
he plays uh
oh really the pam and tommy thing yeah
good for adam man adam's good actor
good guy too
all right yeah there is a video uh
covering dion sanders and his football
career and in the video it shows that he
actually had to have two of his toes
amputated on his left foot it's his big
toe and part of the second toe
yeah unfortunately he had to have the uh
them amputated because he was having a
lot of issues with his left leg and i
guess something to do with like
it was cutting off circulation they just
had to take it off yeah they said
and this video is graphic oh he's gonna
watch it yeah all right wait he's awake
final procedure no he's uh on the
amputation
his wife of uh i believe
and his second toe
which was
very emotional
[Music]
you're talking about your matter four
two three recording yeah
[Music]
is he a waker yeah i think he's just
he's kind of like i think he's down
there look at this all of his toes look
bad though his foot looks bad very good
and it looks a little scary fella oh
he's awake
do you want to look
no the hardest thing of it all
was
to look down and you just want to get
out of this hospital you just want to
get out
jesus christ man oh man
and what what i wonder what all of that
stemmed from
some kind of uh it was some kind of a
complication he was sick
and it was something yeah he's great
barstool is also brilliant for doing all
this
that's [ __ ] crazy what a good guy i
got to know him a little bit back in the
day and uh
i worked with him for a whole hold on
scroll down i want to see what's going
it says amputation became necessary
after sanders suffered complications
from surgery and to develop blood clots
sanders who underwent multiple
procedures last year became aware that
his toes turned black as the bandages
that were on his feet were changed jesus
christ oh [ __ ]
can you still walk without the big toe
the big one
you have to have rehab to learn how to
do it he's athletic the pinky can get
rid of yeah you use your toes for
balance oh yeah maybe he can because he
still has the other one he might have to
kind of adjust the way he throws off a
lot of yeah
[ __ ] up your prosthetic on there so
just so i i think you i think you can
because you're gonna need that like push
off of and
you need your time that's crazy dude
especially about the dionzo
yeah yeah that's a big deal obviously
didn't watch him growing up but i
wouldn't watch his highlights on youtube
oh my god oh he ran out oh my [ __ ]
god no yeah legit just shut down the
corner i'm the best never do it yeah
just ridiculous what else you got jen
it's got to be my so uh during the
war there are a handful of people in the
ukraine who are choosing to take
advantage of the situation and loot
homes businesses
and a lot of locals have seen that and
did not like it so there is currently a
trend where they're catching looters and
either saran wrapping or taping them to
poles with their pants down that's cool
as like a sign
yeah
they're lucky they don't kill them yeah
so this is one and then there's another
photo if you keep scrolling
you know how cold that is right
there that's what you get looting those
poor businesses while they well yeah why
are you getting [ __ ] bombed yeah
what's uh i don't see somebody get blown
up yeah
what happened got blown up look at this
there's tight to the [ __ ] thing yeah
that's right you can't be uh
it'd be fun if you bum the other way
though you'll have the dick out you know
who did most of them no they want that
dick to stick to that pole versus in the
ukraine uh during the crimea war
it was uh neo-nazi groups
those are the hardened like battle it's
really weird because the landscape is
jewish but the the sort of people doing
a lot of this stuff
and a lot of the fighting and stuff are
avowed neo-nazis
well that's putin's whole propaganda
yeah yeah but who knows he's trying to
de-nazify which is a whole different
thing but but i hope the president of uh
ukraine doesn't get killed he's kind of
a badass he gave out his location too
all he has to do is just go look if
ukraine could just say we're we're a
neutral state well that's what he said
now let's say he has he has the the idea
of us being part of the gop i i'd love
to talk about it because we're open to
not being part of gop not gop that's uh
granola
um
nato yeah he was like we're open is that
true yeah because that that's really
smart that's why they seized fire the
other night all they need is just get a
lot worse demilitarized
border you know that you know nato's not
just do it just say we're a neutral
state and become prosperous as [ __ ] and
and just get back to trading you know
[ __ ] man
dude gas prices out here
[ __ ] insane how funny is that trump
like two years ago posted if biden
becomes president gassing me six seven
dollars everyone's like you're full of
[ __ ]
excuse me yeah
yeah and then also to fly anywhere now
like my tickets in nashville's you're
talking about prime time
yeah it's all a [ __ ] nightmare
dude something plain too to fly right
now lanes are so expensive yeah i'm
going to miami and i was like it's nuts
what the [ __ ] are we talking about
i mean
that's what it is yeah that's what the
[ __ ] it is because you know we travel
every weekend yes it gets expensive if
you're bringing other people yeah when
jay told me i'm when jay told me much
nashville was i'm like what was there a
convention it was a a music festival
jay's like no
so he's just that that's how it is the
same thing for springfield
expensive wow yeah i guess
so this poor professor was doing a
lecture and he had the projector on he
had it on his emails which he didn't
take the time to take off and sometimes
professors do that but the students
noticed that in the back one of his
emails was a notification from only
fancy that his subscription was going to
be either like renewed or it was ending
and so
[Laughter]
uh yeah just a little embarrassing
moment for this professor i don't think
anyone thinks he's like a creepy perv
it's just a little embarrassing hey let
him have it let him have it so what he
wants to look at he's a regular dude who
happens to be a professor yeah hopefully
he doesn't lose his job or something no
yeah yeah i would never know it's all
legal
yeah it's just embarrassing and
what else you got
uh i don't know too much about this i'm
sure you know a lot more of the details
yeah the football player calvin ridley
has been suspended indefinitely for
gambling
but he wasn't gambling on any games that
like his team was a part of that that's
what's so you can you can't gamble that
at all oh he's suspended for the entire
next season no not not with gambling
he's
he's suspended the entire uh
2022 season yeah and he's going to pay
oh no no no no my god
there it is the leak sent out press
release today announcing calvin ridley
will be suspended for at minimum the
entire 222 season for gambling nfl games
during a five-day period
oh my goodness this happened while rider
was away from the atlanta falcons on
non-foot so he was even playing and
batting dude he played only five games
um
so goodly announced on halloween that he
needed to step away from football to
focus on his mental health all right
so so that could be the end of his
career i hope not according to the nfl
no games were compromised in any way no
members of the falcons organization were
aware that uh ridley bet on games
isn't that crazy
but it wasn't games that he was in and
had nothing it didn't have anything to
do with the team that he was playing on
yeah he says the new england patriots
and the houston texans are interested in
trading for him yeah because he's a stud
yeah i also heard that the games he was
betting on were like five eight game
like parlays yeah been 1500 bucks it's
just like it's not clearly they just
they just don't [ __ ] around you can't be
in the nfl and bet on nfl games yeah
they don't [ __ ] around
what else you got fair enough
all right let's see here
uh
oh you mentioned this before brandon the
morgan wallin who won the amc album of
the year after being banned from the
acms last year right because the n-word
yeah he's destroying right now and then
even right now
i saw a meme that said i saw me and said
cancel culture is officially over
he also
his album dangerous the double album
officially spent more weeks 59 in the
top 10 of the billboard 200 charts
of all time yeah i think people realize
he wasn't being racist he was just he's
drunk
but he was also not using it in
derogatory term he was saying it to
another white guy yeah he was drunk
which you know you shouldn't be saying
it but also you shouldn't lose your
career and also these [ __ ] country
music stations who took them off the
audience wouldn't excuse me and then
dude he put this history was always my
favorite subject uh in school now i get
to make it
now he's destroying that more weeks 59
in the top 10 of the all-time 200 any
other country album of all time that is
insane dude that's the people fighting
this cancel culture over stupid [ __ ]
yeah the mass is spoke man yeah i love
him he's one of my favorite well because
all of us know that human beings a
little more complicated [ __ ] you say
things you don't follow us everyone says
well you say things you don't mean
something about it it was a neighbor
well he's getting dropped off by uber
he was drunk with his buddy a neighbor
filmed this yeah there you go
[ __ ] that neighbor too oh pieces you're
not making the world and what did the
neighbor get
what did they get out of that yeah
you're not making the world up
cool you're not doing it that's my
problem with all of this it's like
you're not doing anything if i'm morgan
yeah you know
i send that neighbor a care package and
say thank you that's exactly
what it is it's in the album too
i believe
yeah i think that's actually the answer
to everything i did the old story i've
told a thousand times guy gets mugged in
new york city can remember the author's
name he i've always wanted to write a
book he's in the hospital for three
months he writes a book because there's
nothing else to do and then he wrote a
letter to the in new york times thanking
the mugger for [ __ ] mugging him
because he never and i think you can
turn anything like that into amazing you
got to do it what else do you got to do
[ __ ] let it make you bitter and be a
[ __ ] yeah what else you got too yeah
speaking of
speaking of billboard this was very
interesting good transition
okay so this artist i don't really know
much about this artist but so i talked
to my boy adam22 who's like balls deep
in music right because uh
uh some fans sent this to us and then
also mark sent this to us he was have
you seen this guy and i'm not i i was he
had that one rap song you sent to me oh
yeah yeah yeah so his name's tom
mcdonald he's a conservative rapper
exactly or well
right like a right-wing yeah right-ish
but i heard he kind of makes middle
ground points he doesn't everything he's
singing about
is
you know he's independent yeah and so
his he has a weird model i think comics
or whatever business you're in could
learn from his marketing so he he
releases some songs on streaming
platforms which is always because he had
to though basically no he didn't have no
no youtube fine but as far as digital
like it's really some on itunes and
spotify but then he also physically uh
sells his albums
cds oh wow but if you add up his
streaming
and he releases like one ep streaming
then you gotta buy his album and he does
merch he does a bundle of merch in his
album at the same time but if you add up
all that
and he can prove it you add up all that
he's number one on the billboard charts
so he's been doing for a hot second
probably making more money than god he's
crushing it
tom mcdonald so then he documented him
going to billboard and he he said this
though in this video
if you're looking for the video it says
the biggest music industry screw job
ever i can't believe they're doing this
to us it's uh tom mcdonald he's got
three million subscribers
so
he's independent he's self-made he
shoots his videos himself edits him and
him and his girl put everything out
um he does all his merch whatever
crushing it so he his issue isn't with
billboard he's like it's not them they
work with the analytic
independent team that gets all the
analytics of all the music and then
sends them the billboard goes right this
is the top 100. so he goes my issue is
not with billboard it's with the
analytics team so he hits he finds out
who it is hits him up because uh his
girl did first of all because she's like
hey we we should be number one on
billboard this is ridiculous it was cool
send me email
they sent 50 emails in a week they're
going back and forth and they're going
hey these are a streaming numbers these
are our physical album sale numbers
compared to your guys's we're number one
and they go well we don't these numbers
are so outrageous we don't believe you
so he goes cool
we can prove it we'll give you the info
to look at our shop on the back end
access to see how much we're saying all
everything yeah because we can prove all
this
they go down all this all this [ __ ] 50
emails all the [ __ ] they keep asking for
this they give it to them keep out they
give it to them give to them they go see
we're doing it we're doing it we're
doing it finally nothing
he goes all right we'll just give you
the log in the back end of our sales so
you can we can prove it
they just don't want to deal with them
like nope we're good yeah of course they
don't because obviously he's fighting
the system he's not the same right
that's right and he's got a different
narrative and here's the thing no matter
how how you feel about his political
beliefs it's not even about that it's
about this independent artist
has gotten so massive numbers there's
straight numbers of numbers dude they
said he has over a hundred million views
on youtube alone in 2021
over a hundred million yeah
well he has all the back end no this
isn't it's the 18 minutes
basically
i just gave
yeah
and they were so it's a third part
instead of a proprietary um thing that
billboards should be doing i'm guessing
right they should have a pretty system
third-party data collection data uh what
do you call them
potentially yeah i don't know so no
that's
data tracking that's what i'm saying
data tracking so they go to third-party
data tracking place and then i looked up
the data tracking place as well and and
they were telling them like
like okay it's called mrc data yeah
and they were telling like
uh if you have these sales why isn't it
in a pub why can't we find the
publishing for it he's like because
we're doing independently we're doing
ourselves we're packing the cds we have
their warehouse we're we're sending it
out to people individually
how cool is it i love it no but my thing
i was talking to spells right at the gym
i go if i'm him i'm making all that
money
it's kind of like a big comic because
just
crushing like ticket sales yeah their
youtube special crushes it yeah but
whatever reason they want this co-sign
from hollywood go come on netflix come
on he admits that you don't have to do
that you know he admits that later
i mean every single person i guess that
wants to get into entertainment no
matter how like you know you want to be
independent you want to get the
recognition that's kind of hollywood
yeah i get it it's a big record
and if his numbers
you know come to the fact that he is
number one on billboard
i do get it you know it's kind of like
hey we'll give you that frustrating like
no dude the weekend's not number one i
sold more [ __ ] yeah albums but i'm
number one this isn't real yeah i think
to his point it's like billboard it's
not their fault because they're getting
that
yeah but they should have their own
proprietary system i think they really
should yeah if that's your i mean you
probably did at that point and they
probably just hired this third party
because they were just like
so when you listen to the actual entire
youtube video yeah you'll see his
communication and his team's
communication with that uh yeah
he's nuts
that's yeah and then because this girl's
been dealing with it like
exhausting all her resources they have a
guy who's uh high up in music even was
like no these numbers are real man we
know for a fact i work for this you know
network
this would entertain it so then tom gets
on there and he's like yo this is
actually tom and the email he sent he
tears into him but his like vocabulary
super smart guy yeah yeah i asked adam
and because adam 22 knows music better
than anybody and he goes for what he
he's niche he's been doing forever but
he's like the face of it
he's like there's a lot of other white
rappers who you know talk about this
stuff but he's like the guy
but he's saying it's like a niche market
and i guess he gets a lot of hate from
other independent and then i asked adam
i go and they go i guess he's kind of
corny
i think he's great but i guess the
narrative is he's kind of corny but but
i asked adam and he's like i don't know
he's like i don't know him that well but
i asked adam 22 i said
is he getting hate because he's so
popular and successful which we know
happens or is he getting hate because
he's actually corny a bad guy you know
and i'm like i can't answer i don't know
i don't know enough about him i don't
know
yeah i didn't research i tried to
research as much as you can about the
whole data data yeah yeah tracking all
that stuff and this guy as well the one
lineage that i thought where i gave him
legitimacy is that obviously he has like
three million subscribers tons of views
but struggle jennings is one of jelly
rolls dudes as well yeah he's on his
album as well so i was like okay i'll
give him more legitimacy after that yeah
yeah i i didn't look into him as much
because i love this [ __ ] i love this
[ __ ] i you know i don't know his
background but i love it so i was like
oh when they send someone like oh say
less
and then i was like i'm going to support
him by merch
his merch is so intense
how's it going i can't i
they have someone that does it for them
too but it's it's their own team that
does it you don't need that
i get that he wants the notoriety from
like from the billboard but at the same
time
you know i'd be if if i was in his
position no he's super successful
but it would be dope to have billboard
but also a little bit but yeah
and there's a bigger picture when we
think about everything it's like
there's a bigger thing controlling all
this stuff exactly that's what you are
that's what bothers me yes he's done the
work yeah and he's been doing it for
years he hasn't done it at work he has a
date he came back and letting them get
into it and he's like i'll let you in
which is dangerous on my own but i'll do
this just so you guys see what i do and
they still won't validate it yeah
because so it just shows you that there
there is a narrative in music there is
this higher being that controls
everything decides who's who who's you
know it could also be that the people
he's talking to aren't even telling the
higher-ups
it could be that there could be a bunch
of things
not telling the the people at these big
labels and they have their own agenda
sometimes you don't even know who the
[ __ ] you're talking to so it can be that
it's so frustrating when i was watching
that video i'm like oh hell this dude's
fighting the good fight i'm in i'm gonna
buy his merchant support but i was like
[Music]
i don't need a bulletproof vest tom
this thing is hangover gang
no guts no glory shirts
they fake woke they still fake woke i
know we're getting hangover gang sounds
fun
the hangar gang flannels dope no more
snowflakes listen i agree with 99 [ __ ]
but i can't rock it on stage
i'm not you man
night america
yeah but yeah he's good he's great man
tommy's not over one million offended
fantastic
yeah he's huge huh that's great yeah he
even brought up the way that kanye
released his recent album you saw this
thing yeah yeah he even said how like
that made him not billboard uh eligible
because of the way
he released it as
or well like that yeah but he was saying
he was saying so frustrated because he
goes through this whole marketing
campaign this creative campaign that
comes up with to release the [ __ ] which
is crushing again the comics and other
music artists should take notes from no
matter what you think of his music but
you can see with his marketing it's
brailling it's [ __ ] working but he
would sell his album in a bundle with
his merch but then billboard he looked
at all the like rules for billboard you
can't do that you have to just sell the
album so he's like cool we'll do that
we'll still just album still [ __ ]
crush it and then he put on a uh
wait what do you mean he sells justice
album like he he has the apple package
billboard's like it just has to be your
album yeah she said cool i'll do that
and sell shirts opposite of that aside
from it so he's like i'll do that so you
guys are happy with that so he does that
and then they needed like a a code on
the back and he goes look this is the
first cd i've ever done this just for
billboard just so they would be in
compliance still don't [ __ ] with them
it just shows you like there's a higher
like yeah there's a man controlling yeah
and there's you can't have the but it's
also there's a political agenda too
these these yes people are they're just
very much so believe in the wokeness
they are toeing the line it's just not
their complicity my problem is just not
feeling should it work this way
no
like billboards should be very black and
white like i don't give a [ __ ] what
music it is if he's selling the most
that's number one new york times
it's like it's like running a sprint
yeah if that guy runs a 4-2 in the four
this guy runs a 4-8 the around the 4-2
is the fastest yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
what his agenda is i don't care look at
looking you should be the goal new york
times best seller list and whoever wins
awards
all that stuff i know all that [ __ ] like
how many how many did you sell how much
is the new york times counting i know a
lot of authors that are like they're
just not [ __ ] playing fair there is a
there is an agenda there is a political
agenda that's what bothers me it should
bother you it's because it's a it's a
lie but what's interesting and what we
talk about is that you can get away with
that for a while but you ain't gonna
make money the people making money are
the ones that are still standing well in
their music
yeah it might be different but the music
industry is going to wrap excuse me you
have the weekend shut your mouth yeah
all right that's fair yeah
but shout out to tom mcdonald man yeah
yeah that was that was a really good
youtube video
all right um another thing that sucks
with kane velasquez
yeah didn't i yeah about this no they
took down his ghost just go find me yeah
because
it has to do with a violent crime
so they refunded everyone that donated
to his gofundme remember i tried to look
for it on a shop show i couldn't find it
so apparently they they took it off and
they refunded everyone because it has to
do with the violent crimes
even though they didn't really look into
all the details it's just because it has
like you know umbrella violent crime you
got to take it off yeah okay
yeah is there other things is there i
don't know what you do well remember
when they tried defunding the
canadian truckers huge gofundme for them
yeah and they pulled it down that that
was the most outrageous thing
that really made me angry
man
yeah i hope kane's all right man yeah so
sad it said there are a lot of there are
a lot of
charges to fight on this one and a lot
of them in california are to carry some
heavy penalties and this judge the
initial judge is like not a good first
like yeah
they denied him yeah the the female
judge denied him bailly she doesn't know
he's a threat to society i care about
the mma stuff she's not reading those
papers which i think that hurts him
yeah what she's saying is this guy
got into got his truck got in the car
shot into a car with two other people on
a business tried to run them off the
road three times
all that [ __ ] is crazy all that stuff
is is or carries major penalties but
yeah i hope it goes to jury insanity
sympathy absolute insanity they're
certain no that's insane
his case would be in absolute rage and
insanity because he's probably the ct
flared up
that's what you're saying
one of the best lawyers he's doing time
for sure but
hopefully you know only like hopefully
it's not 25 years you know
they shouldn't take it or not
unfortunately
yeah it's tough yeah
all right so this i saw as well uh some
famous korean youtuber who was also a
korean seal for like seven years
he
illegally went to the ukraine to fight
for the ukraine people
right
and now he's being punished
and here's the thing that's weird about
this so people are saying that he's
doing this because he's a super popular
youtuber he's they think he's doing it
for the club yeah for clout but i'm like
you're going there to fight for these
people he already landed there loud or
not either way yeah yeah he's he went to
the way of some [ __ ]
crazy made it as a navy seal in [ __ ]
korea you're no joke yeah and he's like
really popular in korea too i just found
out about this guy and then also let me
see him he's a good looking dude too
yeah
uh scroll down
there go chen
well let me show you some of the
pictures he knows his way around a gun
if he's not yeah who's the navy seal oh
yeah
so he's he should be i think he said
he's in the ukraine right now god i hope
they come to agreement i pray to god
that ukraine president doesn't get
assassinated and this is what he said so
during the korean war the world health
korea which it's true the americans
helped korea as well yeah uh ukrainians
also served in the us army now we will
help ukraine you can't just watch
innocent people get hurt and die please
pray for people he's a wolf amongst he
went there but now he can he's going to
be punished and if he gets back to korea
or he said if he dies he dies but if he
comes back he'll face the punishment in
korea why would they punish him because
he was not allowed to leave the travel
man oh yeah right yeah he did it
illegally yeah ukraine should just grant
him citizenship so yeah he's gonna be
hundred percent right
he'll go back to korea and be a badass
everybody that's the dude right there
yeah that's the dude yeah he's helped
with movies when he goes back to korea
they'll be like oh [ __ ] yes so what a
[ __ ] stunt though man handsome guy
too yeah go back up to the picture with
him and the the gun yeah there you go
ken ree is his name
all right i hope he doesn't die i know
it sucks but i mean
that's cool that he's going there to
protect them [ __ ] yeah
there's no win situation for putin well
hold up no
so all the things that we're doing right
there's no win for russia right this
this so abandon mcdonald's starbucks
netflix it hurts the economy it hurts it
doesn't citizens too that don't want
anything yeah
these uh
things that we're putting on these
penalties it doesn't change putin's life
in any [ __ ] facet that's what people
so when we're doing binds like well
we're not buying oil we're not doing
this boone's like i don't give a [ __ ]
like we're not it's not harsh enough to
make him change all you're doing is all
you're doing is disciplining the the the
people of russia yeah
it sucks for them it's horrible dude it
sucks for them
what else you got jim i see something on
phil collins yeah
it's a tough one no no because he's had
some issues he had nerve damage from a
like a
vertebrae injury so now he can't drum
anymore and this is a picture of him
singing that's phil collins is that
brian
brian on stage
i know
yeah he was a he was amazing drummer
yeah amazing
that's a that's a serious spinal cord
injury so he's like deteriorating yeah
he's a 110.
i don't think he's 110. no no he's like
70 something so he can't 71.72 he
doesn't even look 70 though he can't
walk he has issues walking but he
definitely cannot get an accident is
that what you said yeah some vertebrae
it's brian on stage
dude i'm a robust [ __ ]
ryan's like the best example of like i'm
a robust guy strong dude that's why the
joke's right it is
dude if he was actually that i would not
make fun of him
that would be insanely mean it's a
pretty good joke though yeah but if dude
if you were actually like oh god
i could do that on stage
that would be if i'm like there's brian
and you can't move i mean you know that
you just hope no the only reason we can
no one is joking
yeah i hope i'm your [ __ ] ass don't
be still tournament he's got an amazing
[ __ ] voice
yeah amazing songs let me uh what do we
know what happened though he did what is
it he said of accident with his
vertebrae
they had nerve damage and it's like it's
starting to mess him up can he sing
still i mean yeah he's stinging on the
stage yeah do we have any uh clip of
that
so here
do you do in the heat of the night or is
he tonight
i can youtube
i can feel it
um in the heat of the night is a tv show
yeah what was it called
i can feel it in the air tonight yeah
tonight come on let's see phil collins
phil collins and uh yeah typing field
college 2022
live
hit like there you go three years ago i
was like oh one day one day ago there we
go we probably can't play this bit
berlin don't give a [ __ ]
what do you say
berlin don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]
let's hear them
[Music]
[Applause]
it's very tough
at least
to me it's better than i thought it
would be what's the top what's the top
comment say oh it's tough man worth 300
million incredible voice super talent
songwriter
absolute legend of course i think
it's gonna be all positive news yeah
yeah oh seventy who would hate on him
man i know plus he's
dealing with stuff
but also there could be a very funny
comment in there that's why i was like
what does that mean
how can you hate on phil collins no
all right this is the last you pay to
see this concert
hard pass i like to think of him in his
prime i'll tell you why i loved it i was
talking to my girl i want to go to katy
perry's doing residency in vegas she can
sing oh yeah she's [ __ ] her kills i
don't know if she can sing i find her
insanely oh have you ever heard acapella
oh she's hot oh bro she was a true
singer bro yeah they go hard to paint
stupid
yeah she was eating on the last american
idol
is it me no no well
she's in the world
yeah she's gorgeous she's gorgeous her
body everything about her yeah
i was on a plane where was i going i
think it was sacramento nexter hubby
orlando bloom and i wouldn't be like
dude i'm a huge garry pity okay
yeah
yeah you might you should that was
might be a little light in the ass let
me
give me a call give me a call i'm just
saying if you need some backup you might
need some background backup comments
flying through like the kool-aid man
carry your head talk out you can take a
break yeah we'll see what happens
have you ever seen that clip of her
where uh russell brand
shoots her attacks saying i want a
divorce
documentary right before it's
heartbreaking performing at a [ __ ]
arena [ __ ] russia literally right before
she goes on yeah they're married and
then how about how about this be uh you
know she makes more money russell brand
so they're like oh you're just doing
this for his money and russell brandon
goes i don't want a dime from you i just
want a divorce because he was supposed
to get like 100 million no i don't want
a dime i'm good i love that yeah he's
great brilliant man yeah and she's still
[ __ ] performed wow she was bawling
her eyes i got a text yeah she i saw
something off always like balling her
eyes out oh my god
it's such a nice they're like we gotta
do your makeup we gotta do your makeup
and she was like they're like what do
you wanna do we could cancel it that's
something but she was like nah i got it
i got to do it she's great she's so
pretty yeah she her in uh orlando bloom
have a kid oh now she's a mama uh-huh
good for her
good friend russell brand's married now
with kids too
facts dude him and rogan together is my
favorite i haven't heard listen to it
good episode yeah episodes episodes yeah
he's [ __ ] he's great he's my favorite
on there yeah what does she get jen
uh last one
is it just me is kitty
katy perry hot
no the
excuse me she's just so brian's like hey
dude i want to go on a limb right now i
think rihanna is very attractive but but
katy perry she kind of kills me she's so
curvy and hot oh god all right brian i
know i'm sorry
and i will shout on them um what's this
this is just a
sign language interpreter doing his
thing and then an owl
really big that owl [ __ ] all up on him
thought that [ __ ] was throwing
up games
let me see the original [ __ ] here you go
post 2011 there was a program oh oh it
gets on his face
oh
it's like on his eyebrow does he sign
language oh [ __ ]
he actually says something
like you can talk
like what the [ __ ]
oh he cut his that's a
oh come on no
sorry take your jacket off just now
there's katy perry behind him right
there
[Music]
he's like you got your forehead
got that samurai hair too that's a hell
of a ponytail that's an interesting back
to work some long hair yeah
yeah that's about it massive [ __ ] on
them
is that it that's it all right i'm in
nashville this thursday friday saturday
all shows are damaged sold out except
for the late show on friday
zany's nashville yeah friday can be able
to start friday late we'll see man
zany's nashville we had a special guest
as well jumping up on stage uh and then
chicago is the end of the month if
chinch could scroll down i'm in chicago
march 24th through 26th my outfit is so
[ __ ] fire for that show improv uh yep
improv chicago uh yeah
no that's not fire and then i'm in uh
stand up live phoenix arizona's april
14th through 16th get your tickets right
out thickboy.com flashback fight night
just dropped as well on the think boy
channel with michael chandler and like i
said the next um
uh cowboys fight companion is march 19th
the day after my birthday with jeff dye
crystalia and adam 22 and myself for the
big london card that is at 1 p.m pacific
only on thick boy
phoenix arizona oh tough mudder sorry
tough mudder the thick mudder is april
9th at 10 30 a.m you get 10 off when you
use the code thick boy
phoenix arizona stand up live to this
weekend friday saturday sunday
louisville kentucky louisville comedy
club march 17 through 19. we'll see you
there in miami florida my how many
nights it's about to get steamy up in
that [ __ ] miami improv march 25 26 27
be ready i will be bringing heat
all right and then uh springfield
missouri i will see you this weekend
march 10th through the 12th at blue room
comedy club and then april 8th and april
9th i'll be in salt lake city at wise
guys comedy club
that's it
that's it